todo
[Música]
hola hoy en saint clic el efecto doble
imaginemos dos personas las llamaremos a
y b a comienza a gritar
al hacerlo emite una onda que se propaga
por el aire con una frecuencia
determinada
si la frecuencia es alta el sonido será
agudo
si la frecuencia es baja el sonido será
grave
ve que se encuentra a cierta distancia
de oye el sonido producido ya que recibe
las ondas sonoras con la misma
frecuencia
ahora veamos qué ocurre si se acercaba
nos damos cuenta que las ondas situadas
delante de a se contrae esto implica que
su frecuencia aumenta puesto que la
distancia entre dos picos consecutivos
disminuye
inversamente en el lado opuesto las
ondas se dilatan por lo tanto su
frecuencia disminuye ya que la distancia
entre dos crestas consecutivas es mayor
como la frecuencia a la derecha aumento
de oír a ondas sonoras más agudas
en cambio si estuviese al lado opuesto
como la frecuencia a la izquierda ha
disminuido o iría a las ondas sonoras
más graves
esto es lo que llamamos el efecto
doppler
si un objeto emite una onda sonora con
una frecuencia determinada y se acerca
al receptor este detectará la onda con
una frecuencia más alta
al contrario si el emisor se aleja del
receptor este detectará la onda con una
frecuencia más baja
un buen ejemplo el efecto topless es el
movimiento de un automóvil a medida que
el vehículo está cerca a nosotros oímos
notas altas
y al alejarse oímos progresivamente
notas cada vez más bajas
de manera general el efecto doppler no
se aplica sólo a los sonidos pero
también a todo tipo de ondas por esta
razón cuando una galaxia se aleja de
nosotros la vemos ligeramente más roja y
cuando se nos acerca la vemos un poco
más azul
[Música]